so switching gears a little bit I was
wondering if you could take us back to
where you were in your life when you
switched careers I know you were a
basketball player for a while I know you
grew up in the music business with your
dad but then you played basketball and
then there was a point where you
switched careers you talk about mentally
where you were physically where you were
how was that yeah when I was playing
basketball my dream was to obviously
play in the NBA and had a career-ending
injury which kind of made me change
direction and made me focus or refocus
on music and that was a tough time
because I really had planned on playing
basketball and I'd worked my whole life
to do that but in the long I think it
was a really fortunate turn of events to
get hurt you never think that's a good
thing but it turned me towards music and
it made me really really take all my
energy and effort that I was putting
into basketball and put it towards music
that was right at the time I finished
college so I was young and I could I was
still malleable enough to just adjust
and you know switch into something else
but music was always a passion of mine
when I was a kid I think I started
taking piano lessons when I was 6 years
old 7 years old and it was a hobby all
through college so it was all I always
kept my my my toe in the water with
music and then when basketball finished
for me it was just definitely a kind of
a wholesale refocusing I started doing
jingles and locally in Arizona where I
was going to college I started doing
commercial music and working for ad
agencies and you know I was doing music
for anybody who wanted at break stores
you know buses things like that I would
make a jingle for anybody and all the
while I was trying to get to Los Angeles
to kind of kick in somebody's door to
listen to my music and that took me
probably 3 or 4 years driving out to LA
and for a week at a time listen trying
to get people to listen to my demos I
was sending cassettes to people back
then and you know throwing cassettes and
the people's convertibles and doing
anything I could to get my music heard
and that was kind of how I started here
in LA was just try
being out here sleeping in my car every
now and then whatever I had to do and
then one guy took notice he said hey I
love what you do I'll pay you I think
$2,500 to do a job for him and at that
point that was like oh my god I'm in I
made it and that was my first job Motown
Records I did a remix for one of their
artists and then I ended up here doing
an interview with you
what year was this that was probably 94
something like that okay so you said
earlier that you take a nugget of
something from each project and there's
some lesson in it so looking back at the
jingles maybe creatively it wasn't the
most fulfilling maybe it was what if you
what did you take from that that you use
then to build this amazing studio that
you have here that's absolute beautiful
I tell you how I took so much from that
two or three year period where I did
advertising music because you have to do
every range of music that some guy says
well I want it to be country-western and
lean on my burger joint I feel like it's
you know a country place or a blues
music or I want this kind of music I
don't want classical so you have to be
able to do all that type all those types
of music you have to be able to deliver
it quickly and you have to be able to do
it economically when you're working in a
small market like that so it was an
amazing training ground for me
the other thing that I got from that is
working outside of your own bubble of
creativity like you can't do whatever
you want when this guy is trying to sell
cars with his music you have to do what
he thinks is gonna help him sell cars so
you really have to pay attention to what
people want you have to be able to
translate what they're thinking cuz he's
a car salesman or a break store owner or
a guy who runs a mall he's not a
musician you have to figure out what
he's trying to get to with his music and
figure out how to get it out of your
fingers and out of the speaker's
ultimately so that's what I use every
day with whether it's an A&R guy for a
record label or a director for a film
being able to take what they say and
what they think and what they feel and
making that come to life with music is
something that I do every day so that's
great training and then as I said being
able to do all the different kind of
genres of music and being able to have
access to my background being in all
those types of music I did so many rock
and roll commercials so many you know
classical commercials that I can draw
from that now when I'm when I'm needing
to do a piece of music for a film
you